hello there reject nation we are loading
gravity falls right now because that's
what we're gonna watch today hooray so
if you guys are here stick around by
leaving a like that's the way you get
admission into viewing this video also
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
to the finale of gravity falls is up you
don't need to watch the in between just
see how it goes from here
to the final episode also full length
watch along is recycled with the time
code are available for our super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page thank
you to all who have shown your support
by following us there thanks to the
prepper team for helping us edit that it
is helping down these highlights and no
never gonna watch this let's go
uh that cloud looks like uh
a cloud boom what thompson clearly a
waffle you idiot that cloud looks like a
big heart-shaped balloon clouds don't
come in colors that's like something
else too it's the woodstick festival
wait the wood what it's this annual
outdoor concert featuring oregon's
up-and-coming indie bands hey they're
all coming scarves indoors wood grain on
everything love god that's the name of
the episode
ghosty sounds cemetery ghosty sounds
it's coming from that open grave
yes
you look no you look thompson go look
nice use of thompson
[Music]
gaze upon death i thought they were
saying gays like gay people for like
upon death you will be greeted by
several gays
to escort you to the
gay earth gay gay gay
oh it's even creepier than i expected
robbie we split up forever ago it's
really sweet you throw yourself into a
grave for me but man time to move on
what i've totally moved on
it's harder when you're broken up with
dude this is getting really awkward yeah
the cemetery used to be fun now it's
just depressing
i feel ya
no
how can i be happy if i know someone
else is sad it totally throws off my
happiness chart oh
is everyone happy
you know what robbie needs a new girl
romance is like gum once it's lost its
flavor you just cram another one in
nice
it is if you're the world's greatest
matchmaker i've never had an unhappy
customer like seuss and melody watch
this walker oh
did it look cool
the coolest that's me i'm glad they're
still together it's the woodstick
festival zeus lock down the shack and
hide my shirts before anyone tie-dyes
them
they're slow i can probably take a few
down
yes
how do i appeal to young people
so young people are into hot air
balloons eh
we are i love a good hot air balloon
broken teacup and you're going to piece
them back together
if you were dead you'd be home by now
robbie stacy valentino
there's a little girl here to see you
you go on up and could you bring him his
lunch oh
you know who would look good in a
sweater like that mrs grabelson's
remains oh absolutely i want to see a
dead body oh it's an experience
[Music]
it's like the humphrey house yeah
remember me i'm like girl dipper
ugh go away i heard it come in
you just need a good matchmaker i
guarantee i'll find you true love or
twice your sadness back
get to work but who could possibly be
superficial and gothy enough for
of course that's it you two really are
america's favorite power couple who what
wendy again more snacks more sex oh is
that the other girl
tambry you me date bring that sweet
sweet bod your secret admirer
who is that voice somebody tell me love
is about to happen lazy susan
about our safe dinner we don't have one
tambry let's be real if i wanted to date
you i would have done it already i'm
just a little out of your league whoa is
that mustard don't want to waste that
bad boy
good on you robbie hey can i get some
chili fries to go
what how is this possible i'm supposed
to be the best matchmaker ever
[Music]
the love god
we're rewriting history tonight and it
starts with you and you
oh yeah
oh my love god are you an actual love
god call me a cherub
i've taken some time to focus on my rock
career boom cassette boom for
that's
you
so anyway can you make anything fall in
love well there's trash then hmm my g i
don't know that might be kind of hard to
kaboom match me
[Music]
how are you doing that love potion yo i
got it all summer love young love
anti-love oh
you might think you know what's best for
people but this stuff can have major
social consequences that's why it can
only be used by a serious expert love
god sign my face only if you sign mine
baby let's get weird
all righty
take it
mind if i add a little something to
these fries i don't see why not
oh oh no
[Music]
whoa did your whole thing suddenly get a
lot more likable i'm gonna want to maybe
get out of here and i don't know
go kiss in public a lot for some reason
i do
status update
[Music]
forget it
maybe i should stare at something other
than my phone for a while
but don't leave your phone you might
need your phone i brought a baggie of
trail mix and safety whistles in case we
get
separated this kid is a champion dipper
thompson's such a loser
this is so like tambry to do this date
my ex behind my back i'm gonna tear her
highlights out guys guys we're gonna be
late for the concert uh news flash kid
i'm not going to the concert not with
him hey that won't be a problem cause
i'm out me too
guys
match
made
god damn it mabel we were all starting
to finally hang out together i was one
of the gang well unless you can break up
robbie and tambry immediately there is
no gang i have no more friend breakup
god undo it oh that's it if i undo the
spell then everyone will be friends
again but i'm gonna need your help or
take it for him and wendy balloon faster
seuss we need this thing up in the air
before the festival ends are you sure
that that open flame should be that
close to that dangling cloth and rope
i'm sure about everything now lube up
those engine gears with some kerosene
more kerosene
the tickets were 100 bucks i sold my
watch you gotta come to the concert ill
and have to look at that no thanks
you guys learn to be happy for them
love god sound check for love god
oh let's make some miracles happen
groupies bed had me
that what were they doing in there there
was a yeah there was a menage a love in
there
oh anti-love to reverse the effects of
love potion simply spray on your victim
and watch their heart die on the inside
sounds good to me hey
you're the one who's been stealing my
stuff i am not loving this huh
on my oath as a god i cannot let you oh
hey where'd you just go i'm sorry i love
no but it's for the good of my friends
come back here
i'm gonna miss soundcheck
get those kits
out we mustache you to move
just one clean shot to the back of their
heads and everything's fixed
sorry kids but you've left me no choice
visions of heartbreak pass
we're back mabel oh we like you now
oh you really think we'd fall for that
sure you can all marry me
letter rip
oh no a letter rip
what the h
oh god
i eat kids
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes charlie yes he will
[Music]
my god
sorry kids but that's what happens when
you mess with a god only a greener being
from the heavens themselves could
possibly stop
it's coming down
[Music]
oh
kill the god oh no i hope someone didn't
die yes that would be
awful mabel i just wanted to thank you
i've been so miserable since wendy broke
up with me that i thought my life was
over but you were right
i just needed to move on
[Music]
i'm
happy weird huh oh no guys i made a
friendship cake so let's all get over
this okay
my cake
mug
oh man yeah fight the machine thompson
throw snacks at him use jerky as a
weapon thompson
so cool thompson
[Music]
maybe someone up there really is a
genius matchmaker all according to plan
[Music]
[Laughter]
i missed the names of everyone who
played everyone i tried to catch it but
i was distracted by the visuals on
screen oh
it's okay
if only there's a way we could go back
but it's hard believe it or not on
streaming
why'd you take your headphones off not
you oh yes everyone but you john making
that mistake taking the day yeah
flashed back for a moment uh months ago
yeah yeah if only these things were on
demand
the reason it's hard is because
because all these lives there's a friend
there's just forwarding
skip button for everything and you can't
just fast forward and do it
you can't it's too complicated we're not
doing it or let's talk about the episode
so yeah love god who voiced him you
think louis anderson yes it was
definitely louie anderson
is louie anderson still alive
i might have been when this came out as
possible actually this is many years old
now uh
i will arnett
definitely will arnett it's that deep uh
uh oh how about um
nick
stop stop it [ __ ] you went too far
oh wait wait no no we can go back we can
go back john don't mess this up for
everyone well we're gonna a little bit
too far back
these streaming services are so
difficult they stretch me out so much
i know none of them have good fast
forward go back and rewind
none of them have have good fast forward
rewind mechanics more they all go yeah
yeah okay okay
all right all right so we go to the next
page john dimaggio
bender from futurama or jake the dog
from adventure time among various other
voices i don't know who that is who's
the girl tambry jessica diquito
[Music]
and yorma tacone from the lonely island
was gabe
the character was gabe
gal gadot plays wendy friends that's
right always
well all right
i thought that'd be more exciting with
her israeli accent of whoever it was but
that was a sweet one
that was a sweet episode everyone was
indeed
to get robbie getting a chance at love
getting a chance to move on
in a very natural way
force drugged way yeah
that's the way to do it man but it
worked out hey man as long as whatever
substances lead you to finding love that
is love
at the end of the day so i guess that
potion just lasts forever i guess so
forever ever forever ever forever ever
forever ever i don't sleep
i don't eat
i do nothing but
think of you dream of you dream of you
yeah
keep me under your spell you keep me
under your spell
hey matt
you talked to mark lately
he looks pretty uh yeah he looks pretty
uh down
steal my sunshine oh hey that's right
i'm so used to hearing this on the radio
you talked to mark lately
i haven't really talked to anyone lately
it looks pretty uh down it looks pretty
uh down
should we cheer him up then yeah
see like butter types
i was lying on the grass of sunday
morning of last week
anyway
that's
still my sunshine
oh yeah len good old glenn
hiya bobby i can that's another song
with yeah it's another song with a
dialogue intro with a scene to kick
things off about love sort of not as
overtly
yeah
sunshine
well um yeah i think robbie and tambry
are a better mix both goth straight out
of hot topic
the devil's store scene kids
yeah and satan satan shops there you
can't interview with people's love lives
man you can't do it never go i want to
see well it kind of goes well
eventually
afterwards the message almost seemed
like ah you know people will be mad for
a second but then don't get over it
i mean
you know
i matched up dan and alyssa and now they
never talk to me see you're just too
good of a matchmaker
yeah i'm ignored
so what are you to do we can get some
anti-love i don't know why dipper wasn't
tempted at all
i'm just saying man if
i was younger i'd be foolish enough to
do that
yeah i mean he's already undergone that
character growth he probably knew he was
like ah
i don't want to regress my own arc who
cares it's true something happened
yeah why not
is that any different than controlling
an ai in westworld
yeah it's okay it's okay to do that in
in an ai scenario and what is what is
the difference between ai and humans
really
see
you're fine
yeah i grew up he filled out like a real
person in love
gameweek like a slob
a love slob
stop trying to be attractive
so you keep the relationship alive
i thought he was fun
i liked watching him set people up he
was fun this was enjoyable
really strong b story with stan
definitely was a story
it was definitely a story
rather than like
it was like three panels of a comic
strip we come back to
but i do appreciate his big burning
visage
just you know
towering down i thought this would have
crumbling episode would uh amount to
something more in line with that but i
guess it kind of does dramatically about
peace
love taking drugs to alter your state of
consciousness into feeling more love
it is an interesting switch up in that
yeah you would almost figure like stan
trying to appeal to the youth
and the festival itself you would think
would make a lot more of a
would be a lot more focal or something
like that rather than just the set
dressing
you guys want a real challenge
you got to keep this perfectly leveled
straight
oh that would be so hard
i don't think he could even do it for
like one second
it's hard to do just like one straight
second it's a problem
it's a problem with independent
all-wheel drive you know
true you need some kind of fixed machine
chevy
uh
relay
i actually thought the episode just
didn't
yeah it was fun it was pleasant it
wasn't one of the more like i i enjoyed
the kind of intermixturing of characters
and some of the like thompson
you know like i like the settings and
the places and and like the cherub
character but it didn't feel like one of
the more
vital
there's some like wrap around a message
here and i'm like this is kind of a
messed up story
yeah it's funny it's i like it could it
could be worse but it is that thing of
like mabel does mess with the laws of
reality and stuff and she does like
brainwash these two people into love
and then it just kind of works itself
out like they said it's just bullied and
thompson you know yeah gets gets uh
caught up by the guards and then they're
like yeah
the way to get over uh past love is to
find someone else to fall in love with
yeah that's right you know
don't don't get over kind of a weird
episode don't heal your trauma from that
relationship before getting into a new
one yeah it's kind of a weird weird
episode and uh
yeah yeah
what are you gonna do
not everyone's a home run all right no
you're gonna start uh trying to love
potion all your friends that's what i
got out of this it's going to work
that'd be so cool
i used to look at him buying pheromones
really no
because everyone saw ocean 13 and it was
like
is that real
it is that wow i didn't yeah i forgot
about that aspect of ocean's 13. did you
find some did you did you buy some i'm
using it right now
no wonder you look so lovely today
geez did you do something different with
your hair yeah it's uh
it's not uh
i don't think it works
i've never actually bought it or tried
it
oh well you messed up it would be a fun
experiment sure
it would be
the experiment right
see it and just like
let me interact with some strangers and
see if i'm suddenly more attractive to
them but they just come on to me
aggressively it'd be a fun experiment
people are just like hey
who i don't know who you are but i'm
just compelled to talk to you
it's gotta be awesome it's got this urge
to be close to you
can't make a pheromone strong enough to
pierce the deviated septum
one that that has like dude i was gonna
say like this they don't really have
like a a discernible smell do they
uh
i don't know if it's sentiment it can't
be sent basically cause like no that's
impossible i don't know how many of this
is possible but
but i don't think
it's scent based because yeah you like
sense that's like chemicals they're
secreted enough that like another person
can sense them but i'm also like it's
it's got to be on a primal level it
can't be on like yeah yeah you're right
unless it just smells like a a body
i don't know hell's like flesh
but it would be fun to try that out
yes
let's do it let's do a vlog i mean
let's see something
how much do they cost
i
feel like they'd be like in the ballpark
of like 60 to 70 dollars
by pheromones
for
attraction
what is that the
key word i don't know sure
pheromone spray to attract men all right
okay let's see uh what it's like
for all you ugly ass woman out there
who don't know how to get a guy offer on
men pheromones
pheromones.com oh my god
seduction in a bottle start your love
story with just one spray pheromones for
men and women yeah okay let's look out
for for men yes we are men
56 90. jesus christ max attraction gold
contains eight optimized pheromones to
give you maximum potency and allure it's
scented
uh it helps you get noticed by women by
blending 38 milligrams of total
pheromone content with the purest
ethanol bases
available that'd be hilarious
aware confidence enhancer that's only
thirty eight dollars oh where is it wow
scent of arrows musk fragrance jesus
christ
oh my oh my god
what is the science here what is this
[ __ ] for real oh but if we buy two cent
of eros musk we get the second one fifty
percent off oh that's an even better
deal come on sponsor us come on guys
sponsors
and get this pheromone [ __ ] and we'll
get a sponsorship i want a great ad pick
up your election
we went out there and
we had it was
there's a parade of women out there
right now they will not leave us alone
see the problem is we're looking at
these products and now i'm thinking
there's got to be a youtube review
there's a guarantee
there's got to be a youtube review of
this do pheromones work
uh
deuce activity in other individuals
most insects use pheromones to
communicate oh cool
the research suggests that these are
ineffective oh
there's only one way to find out
my credit card
let's go all out yep yep i think that's
the logical progression of things that
would be such a fun hitting camera thing
to try out
yeah all right guys i got pheromones on
me i want to go talk to some women and
i'll let you know how this goes plus all
the different ways you could warp that
experiment it's like okay today i'm
wearing the men pheromones now tomorrow
i'm wearing the women pheromones and
let's just see
see who comes up to me
how strong they can be what if we could
really put it to the test you were the
first we could be like hey you ugly
skank
they were still attractive
hey you bloated
wanna hang out
it worked i i i do let's go i don't know
why but i normally wouldn't accept this
kind of talk but there's just something
about you
it's that
car spell you have to do that doesn't
mean it's his way of flirting it's his
way of flirting i want to rescue him
yeah
all right guys
well
if you haven't already that's how we
research here which is one keyword yes
no this one paragraph said it doesn't
work it doesn't work
um research
all right
hey let's do a picture
the ogre man we're like who'll be a love
god here and it's the ogre man
he goes out in the streets slays
not actual literal slaves like murders
but slaves oh yeah
chicks that's right and now you might be
asking yourself
how does an ogre man slay well
it's cause he bought some pheromones max
fair attraction
right he was the special discount and
where the original price was 99
and instead ogre man spent 56.90
to get himself some ladies and he it
works can you imagine being a man ogre
going out in public oh my god how would
you ever succeed
with picking up women how can you call
yourself a love god key secret he's got
some pheromones attached to him at all
times and today
he's created very uncomfortable
situations when he's around
um you know family
females
sister his children his mom elderly it
is so uncomfortable for him when
suddenly they are attracted to him
causing all kinds of confusing emotions
for them what a weird time and then when
it really becomes weird is when he loses
all side of logic as well
and stops going oh my god is it the
pheromones and then he questions it
himself am i attractive to my cousin
am i attracted to myself oh my god uh
that's right because pheromones they
reflect
yeah so
dude i'm sorry that uh your sexual
appeal is just
damaging at this point through the roof
yeah it's it's it's a detriment to us
all really ogre man
look
it's a gift and a curse believe me
i know yeah
constantly having a punch woman to get
away from
[Music]
my complimentary chips at this bar i
just want to enjoy my chili fries and
ponder my bottle of max attraction gold
for men you know ogre man you can get
two bottles for 91 which is less than
the price of one box so you should
really talk to them about some kind of
spokes model thing it's the only thing
this company's missing i i think we
should
try to get sponsors from them
ah you know
the sad thing is i'm sure they would
sell
depending on how you pitched that i'm
sure they would give us the talking
points to be like
you won't believe it but it works like i
gotta know if it works first before i
tell people i gotta yeah
of all products
i can't can't accept third party
approval on that gotta see for myself
first hand
well thank you ogre man for endorsing
max attraction gold for ben yep keep
beating off those ladies
[Music]
you